play us a song all right are you guys
ready
oh my gosh maybe not
really slapping those strings
hello everybody welcome back to the
quarter digital podcast
nico wanted to hear a song i didn't have
anything prepared so i just figured i'd
give you guys that little interlude i
don't think half of you like to hear me
sing anyway but uh you know what for the
half of you who do thank you that was
some wonderful singing yes
hey look i'm sorry we we had to miss a
couple podcasts uh over the last few
weeks because uh it's just been real
chaotic in the studio with uh punch for
punch son of a dungeon a bunch of other
productions going on so um
but uh we missed two i don't know if
anyone noticed but
we're back now we're back
wait straight up two
well we missed
we did every other week for
so it wasn't two in a row it was one we
missed one then we had one then we
missed one then we had one
so but anyways um
ren
hi
let's start with you buddy all right
heard you guys talk about me on the
previous podcast
i asked for a red cast but they ran out
of red so i got
black oh okay
yeah so what yeah let's let's hear it
man
um i i
got a boo-boo and
that's about the end of that
that's the end of that story
nothing else to be said yep you know
what number what number broken bone is
that for you you really want to say this
out loud okay
yeah everyone wants to know
it is funny being able to say this at
the doctors and just see all of their
like anyone at the doctor's office like
their jaws just dropped this is bone
break number 18.
it's almost all the bones those bones
are old enough to smoke
yeah
that's 18 divided by 204 that's how many
bones there are in the body or is it 196
or something so i i want to clarify this
because i mean let me do the math on
this go ahead
well this is the fourth bone break since
march of 2021
so i i started by breaking my shoulder
and then that was going to require a
bone break yes i thought there was like
a cartilage tear it was both
it was uh the thing that
surgery was the the the labrum which is
the forward like little buggy bumper on
the front of your shoulder there
that got torn open and that doesn't like
just heal on its own so that needed
surgery but they also had to fix a
couple bone chips from the underside of
the like the shoulder like the socket
bone i guess had a couple chips that
they had to like
thread into place somehow i'm not
exactly sure but
then the collar sorry so i was getting
surgery for that scheduled when i broke
the collarbone so then that had to get
delayed and that was a whole thing and
that took up the majority of my year
last year then back in april of this
year i broke my toe something i haven't
talked about at all yet and then two
weeks ago after the one world race in
san jose
i broke my hand specifically my thumb
the the big metacarpal this bone right
here
uh
got snapped kind of by the base of it
and the whole top part of the thumb got
shot downwards into my hand about an
inch
so you jammed it
yeah i mean it was it got shorter
i didn't jam it
it snapped in half and then got jammed
so it's like um
like
two two broken 8.7 percent of your bones
friend
8.7
that's not true either that's that's
assuming that every time i've broken a
bone it was a different bone
which when i was a kid i broke my arms a
lot
i was very
visual with that just
your arms are always broken as a kid
just yeah kind of
both of them always shout i'm surprised
you don't have like forearms i still
like the length of like an
eight-year-old
now a matching thumb
oh i can't wait to tell you the story uh
my dad just uh reminded me of last week
after the surgery i had totally
forgotten it but
i'll get to that in a moment so most of
the time i broke my arm it was in my
wrist and so it wasn't that big of a
deal because i would like fall over i
was a very impulsive stubborn accident
prone kid and i would fall down a lot
and this was before i learned how to
like roll
and so i would lock my arm out and i
would slip and i would just land with
all my force onto my arm most the time
just a little bone in my wrist would
crack but it counted i'd have to put a
cast on for six weeks
um
one time i bent my leg bone i was like
five or six i jumped off of a
monkey bars and landed on my sister's
face and my leg just bent around her
face i was young enough that my bones
were able to flex rather than break and
so they just set it in the doctor's
office by bending it back oh my god my
parents told me that they really regret
that because i yelled too loud um oh my
god
bones yeah like when you're young your
bones are kind of rubbery bone defender
i think when you set it back he he
introduced a bunch of cracks into my leg
uh
doesn't matter my leg is fine but
because of how long i had a cast on my
left foot is about a half size smaller
than my right foot
you have all these little parts yeah
so then like i would break i would crack
usually it was never a clean break
usually it was just like a crack you
know and that
isn't exactly as bad as a break but you
still have to go through the same sort
of procedure as a cast for six weeks all
that stuff and so my worst break was
when i was like seven years old i think
i was in second grade i jumped out of
the truck bed when we're out camping
i'd my sister and i were playing catch i
threw the ball it went over her head she
missed it and instead of being normal
and going around the truck i decided to
jump and climb up into the truck bed and
then launch myself out the other side
but my shoelace caught on a hook
and i just like swung around and dove
into the ground snapping my arm in half
basically right here my whole arm just
like flipped backwards
hold on a second now you saw it you saw
it
jiggly it stayed there it wasn't
something i saw it stayed in that
position my arm was like imagine bending
your arm upwards like this but instead
of at the wrist it's halfway up your arm
and we're out camping this is when i
lived in i grew up in louisiana family
vacations left and right and and yeah
we're out uh ken cade lake i believe is
the campground it was like two hours
from lafayette where i grew up and so
they yeah we went to a hospital all that
stuff got surgery they tried to set one
bone but the other bones start like
poking out and so they tried to set that
bone and then the first bone started
poking out because both of these bones
broke so they ended up having to put two
big metal plates in titanium plates with
four titanium screws on each of those
plates do they leave those in no because
i'm seven years old my arms are still
growing and so they have to leave it in
just long enough for the bone to grow
and then they go back in and they remove
that stuff
but
however there was a time period there
where it was healed up enough
that i could still continue doing
taekwondo
oh i think i told you this story earlier
this weekend
and so i went to a tournament i have it
i went to a big taekwondo tournament and
uh i was in the sparring uh it wasn't
like a
i was in the championship essentially i
was i was in the finals uh facing off
against this other dude uh we're kids
you know it's not like this is a type
of champion wait was it like that final
scene in the all valley tournament in uh
karate kid and it's like
the mat and the lighting and like the
crowd and like the pressure was it like
that no yes okay
let's just pretend like it was like it
was one of those things we're in like a
big stadium this may have been in new
orleans i can't remember
maybe baton rouge but there's like a
bunch of different squares where like
you have like five to ten kids doing
like you you do like forms and whatnot
and you get judged on how well you can
do the form and then you'd have these
sparring competitions and i was in the
finals of my bracket of sparring and i
blocked a kick with my arm and it hurt
real bad enough that like we had to stop
everything i was like crying and stuff
and
my granted this is what my dad told me
last week he's eat he's like
bad father time here but
i was like you're fine get back in there
and so i did i got back in the match and
i won i won the tournament and i got
first place i got those big fancy
trophies and then we went to the
hospital got my arm x-rayed and it had
cracked right along the screw there
because it's a stress concentration so i
i won the tournament with a broken arm
again dude you pulled a carry stroke do
you remember that gymnast who landed on
one foot and like won the olympics yes
yes
wow yeah
i mean i wouldn't compare myself to that
but
it was this is not like i don't know i'm
not let's let me let me do it yeah
it actually was it wasn't too big of a
deal but
yeah because it just meant i had to wear
another cast for another six weeks it
was it wasn't too big of a deal yeah i
mean whenever we keep going so yeah
that's that
i
growing up my whole life i i would
always say that i had 13 broken bones by
the time i was 12. that was like and i'm
because i remember doing the math like
or not necessarily that was the thing
that was what i always knew totaled up
and i hadn't ever really broken anything
since then until a few years ago we're
in vegas and i broke my kneecap
after nab because i was
i was a little soft
i had been taking pools out of bottles
no i was alone no one was there i was
alone
because i was trying to meet up with you
guys you guys were doing that freaking
dangling sky glide thing and i was
trying to get to that location
i remember you jumping over there yeah
yeah yeah
it was i was alone i was by myself i was
coming from the freaking pinball party
that you guys didn't go to
uh yeah no so i'm in a i'm in a casino
and i need to get to the other side
there's like this long row of empty
tables like blackjack tables or poker or
something but they're all empty and it's
like this big open like vegas
20-foot tall ceiling hallway right and i
need to get to the other side of these
tables to go out the exit on the other
side and it's roped off and i'm like
screw it who cares i'm going to jump
over this rope i'm going to go through
here
like the rebel i am and just get out of
the casino taekwondo champion you can do
what you want
years ago dude look out
yeah so i jumped over the rope but my
foot didn't clear it and so instead of
coming down on my foot my foot got
pulled backwards and all of my force
landed on my kneecap and it didn't break
my kneecap in half but it did crack in
enough that bone marrow leaked out and
formed a bone spur on my kneecap that
was like
2017
i remember we were all packed into this
huge suv driving back and i was in the
very very back cramped up like this
being like guys my knee hurts i don't
know what i did it really hurts
yeah you got to watch the tow hitch man
when i used to do the steeplechase in
college which is the one where you jump
over those four by four posts on the in
the middle of the track
is there water on the other side yeah
there's one that has water yeah
and but if you go over with your toe
down
you know so we would do these exercises
to practice turning our foot to the side
as a habit when you would go over the
hurdle so that way your your toe
wouldn't hitch on it oh i'm following
now yeah yeah and one time i went over
one of those things and it was 100
meters to go
and i went over one of those things and
i didn't bring my knee up far enough and
it just
i just i just like the top of my knee
not like the front plate but like right
above it
and i just i just
punk and then i got up and kind of
stumbled stumbled to the finish
but uh yeah you got to watch those toe
hitches especially in casinos they'll
get you
but i would i would say that i've been
pretty good about not injuring myself
devastatingly over the last two decades
until about a year ago when i started
just going ham
well yeah you heard that we're gonna
film son of a dungeon as is tradition so
we must always have a broken bone inside
of a dungeon so
you know for the first first production
you had your broken collarbone no no so
for the first production i had just had
surgery on my shoulder like a week or
two before and so that was a thing and
so because that was like a tissue
problem i couldn't
move my arm without fear of perhaps
tearing what was holding it all in place
and so that was why i had to have my
arms secured to my chest here
and then you had the shoe my collarbone
was already fully healed that's true
then you had the shield that we just
attached the shields here yep yeah so
you're always carrying a shield
your arm is actually in a sling behind
the shield
yeah and so yeah that was that that was
a fine week it worked out well and so
we've had three different shooting
sessions on the green screen for son of
a dungeon for season two this year the
first two went by fine except for the
fact that you had a broken collarbone on
the first session yeah what is going on
here
telling you is there's something about
it at this point it's not just a
coincidence anymore it's the show
but then yeah so then uh
i guess two weeks ago at this point we
were doing son of a dungeon shooting and
that was that whole week there i had my
my thumb was pretty broken it was pretty
dang broken yeah so yeah for some
context on breaking my thumb i was at a
one-wheel racing event up in san jose it
was the western qualifiers and i was
going hard i was going it was this is
some of the most intense one-wheeling
i've ever done in my whole life some of
the best one-wheeling i've done in my
whole life too and
i placed well
i
got through everything it did okay and
it was
all of this sketchy stuff i was fine
totally fine uninjured except for like
the falls that i took that bruised me up
that's fine it was literally like a few
minutes before the awards ceremony it
wasn't even awards it was like literally
them saying who had the top eight times
out of the 80 people that showed up were
you one of those guys no i was not i i
ranked 26 which i was pretty
disappointed with to be honest but i was
only a few seconds away from the top 15
and i had my first
now we're talking about one willing and
i want to defend my position here yeah
basically i i could have gone a little
faster i know i could have gone faster
but i wanted to have a clean run because
every time you fell off one of the
features you had a 10 second penalty and
so my first run i was focused on making
a clean run
uh being conservative and i was and i
still laid down a pretty fast time but
the second run i was like okay time to
go fast and i was booking it so hard i
was doing well but then i fell off a
couple features and took like 20 seconds
of penalties so that time was okay it
was gross so
yeah whatever um i get to the end today
i'm not expecting to place well and i'm
just kind of like we're it's at a skate
park it's lake cunningham's
uh skate park up in san jose and super
awesome place if we ever get a chance to
go back there we gotta go back there um
and so there's this huge tunnel it's
like a it's like a big tunnel that goes
down into the skate park thing
and
i was just riding around the outside of
it and i had some friends up on top of
the tunnel and i was looking ahead and i
see that there's nothing ahead of me
there's some shadows from a rail up
above onto the
the sidewalk there i'm like okay and i
look back up to the my friends who are
up on top of the
the big tunnel thing and bodhi was one
of the guys and
uh one of the best one runners out there
just saying
i didn't see the rail that was blending
in perfectly with the shadows it was
perfectly front on so it just looked
like a strip
that was the exact same shape and color
as the shadows from the rail up above
and it perfectly coincided i just didn't
see it and i hit it and so it stopped
the one wheel flat i fly forward slam or
i sandwich my hand between the rail and
my hip i continue to flip over my feet
are now up in the air and i'm sliding
along on my helmets upside down before
eventually
falling over on the back side and i'm
like completely dazed uh some of the
guys who uh ran over who had seen it
said that i was knocked out because i
was kind of there for a few seconds then
i tried to get up and i collapsed back
down
and i'm like
wow uh we checked for a concussion no
concussion i'm pretty sure i'm fine
pretty sure pretty sure
and yeah and so i was like okay and so i
get up and i'm like man my hand hurts
and i like i press it i just feel it
shift i'm like okay this is either
broken or
dislocated i've never heard of this spot
dislocating but i assume it's possible
and
so jan didn't actually i was there at
the competition with jan
uh he wasn't at that specific spot but
he was around the corner so he came
around i'm like alright dan we gotta go
i broke my hand and he's like what
and
yeah cause apparently i was so casual
about it that he just didn't quite
believe me at first this is something
i've learned about myself when it comes
to like traumatic moments i tend to get
very calm and focused
and clear-headed which is good thank god
i tend to not panic in in extreme
situations like that same thing when
when
yeah i don't yeah i want to go into it
when obi died it was uh i was very calm
and collected we got yeah it was a thing
but
this is what i noticed last year when i
broke my shoulder no
collarbone you were there you helped me
get the my sweatshirt off yeah i
remember the first thing is like i
really like the sweatshirt they're gonna
have to cut off me with scissors if we
don't take it off right now
that's good thinking yeah and because
like i got you i take i put shirts on my
babies all the time
actually no you only had one kid at the
time this is uh so
oh you're right with with the rise of uh
personal electric
vehicles
uh scooters skateboards one wheels
have you seen a direct correlation
in the rise of broken bones yes okay as
a general trend yes because
there are more this is the law of
numbers right it's like
you take a percentage of anything let's
say one percent of all eevee writers out
there will eventually break a bone
yeah and if that number of if the total
number of ev writers is 100 then there's
only one person but the total number of
people writing these things and i'm not
talking about just one wheels i'm
talking about
uh electric skateboards scooters all of
that stuff euc's the electric unicycles
yeah that number is growing pretty
rapidly and so just by necessity the
percentage
with the assuming the percentage doesn't
really change like the number of people
getting injured is going up
right the thing i've noticed is that i
only ever get injured when i stop paying
attention to the road to the moment i
mean that's kind of a rule yeah yeah
it's a rule that i've i try to live by
and it's like
had i actually been looking forward the
entire time i may have seen the the rail
at the last moment and been able to
dodge it i'm good at dodging stuff at
the last moment
but the fact of the matter was i in the
maybe the two or three seconds leading
up to the hit i wasn't looking
same thing when i broke my collarbone
last year i didn't pay attention to the
battery level on my onewheel it was
around 30
and with how batteries work yes it may
have 30 battery capacity left but it
doesn't mean it has full power
and so i tried to catch up with sam on
his e-bike and i just tried to pull too
much power out of the onewheel i wasn't
even going that fast maybe 17 or 18. you
go pretty fast i mean okay let's say i
was going 20. the onewheel shouldn't
just nose dive at 20 miles an hour but
because it had a low battery it couldn't
output the power and i didn't
accommodate for that and so i went down
the shoulder when i broke my shoulder
there was a
a sewing machine in the sidewalk and i
was like what the heck is that as i'm
like riding by it and i hit like a
little divot in the sidewalk it rolled
the one wheel out from under me i
literally just collapsed i went straight
down and landed on my elbow causing my
shoulder to explode out
same thing when uh before the ted talk a
few years ago uh
when i went to go pick up my shoes from
the the thing i'm going down through
skid row and i hit a i was like oh i'm
coming up to a t junction here i need to
either turn left or right i'm going to
open up google maps to see which one it
is i hit a pothole i didn't see it
because i was on my phone just for a
second
and that was that was i've crashed
pretty hard and gotten uh in two
different locations one in skid row one
at the rose bowl during a soccer
tournament so there's tons of white
people everywhere
in skid row a couple uh homeless dudes
came around over like i saw the whole
thing helped me up they were great when
i uh crashed at the rose bowl
a lot of people saw me everyone ignored
me um and i was like writhing in pain in
the middle of the street and there's
like a car just patiently waiting for me
to just get the hell out of the way
honking you
yeah i suppose i suppose that was yeah
that was a side point but yeah it's you
oh that's why i always feel kind of
safer whenever i'm pushing it hard one
wheeling because
it demands 100 of my attention i'm sure
you understand it's like when you're
riding on a trail it's like you you
can't have the luxury of just like let
the dial look at the scenery it's like
no you're literally looking at the 10 to
30 feet in front of you and that's the
only thing you're focused on right and
when that is the case i never hurt
myself yeah
one wheels freaked me out
i mean i've been on it one time with you
and i literally felt like a little baby
i've never felt more like a little baby
in my life i mean
before then it's for people who don't
want to do one for little babies
it's like i don't know i
i'm head i'm
i want more people to ride one wheels
it's my favorite thing in the world
despite having broken four bones in the
last year i haven't broken any bones in
the one wheel i have a good baby oh that
was
i very much was like i'm going to send
it
i didn't send it
yeah
you forgot to put the postage on the
letter
return to center who hesitant i i didn't
grow up riding anything that required
balance so i'm wondering
about getting a balance board or
something would that help because i feel
like to go just to a one wheel directly
from nothing like never skateboarding
that's what jan did
and it worked for him
did you have a balance board no oh he
went straight to the one wheel he had
never skateboarded or snowboarded or
surfed or balanced boarded anything like
that and he just got a one wheel well he
he got a one wheel as a gift and it was
a very nice and lucky gift and he was
like okay and he it took him about a
month or so to really get his bearings
and like now he's he raced at the race
okay he placed okay i think he got like
61st or something like that out of the
77 or 80 people there so but don't
forget these are like the top writers in
the country showing up so it's like
arguably the world yeah yeah my goals
list just has don't fall on it so do you
ride a bike you know i ride a bike i
know how to ride a bike i was a late
bloomer with a bike for sure didn't you
say snowboard
i have snowboarded okay maybe i'm
thinking of thinner but i just yeah
fenner's fenders
yeah yeah so they all have the the
inbuilt balance but i've gone
snowboarding like twice in my life
and i spent most of the time sliding on
my back down the mountain you know as
you can expect and
yeah i just i it's annoying because
there's so many things i want to do that
require balance
and i feel like i just need the push
to consistently do it but with these
roads out here these these dirty la
pothole ridden roads
yeah and like everyone comes in with
broken bones and you know that's my
that's my sad
sadness is that like
i love this so much and yet i feel like
i'm just pushing people further away
from one wheeling and that's what i
don't want but i i also can't sit here
and be like oh yeah it's safe it's
totally fine it's obviously not yeah you
do run a risk every time you get on the
board that you will get catastrophically
injured yeah but
i don't know i mean you just
don't go faster than you're willing to
fall yeah yeah christian cruises on it
yeah christian goes fast yeah yeah yeah
you you were riding yours inside the uh
the alamo theater
like we were we were going to the
theater and he was literally riding
through the hallway
like
so awesome things like the one wheel
that like i think makes it different
than pretty much every other
electric vehicle out there it's like the
only e-vehicle you can pick up and carry
with you when you walk through the door
of your destination
restaurant skateboard
electric well i guess electric
skateboard yeah no that's something okay
electric skateboards are in the same
class because they're not nearly as like
versatile they're a lot lighter than a
one wheel
but versatility absolutely i hear you
there i'm i i rode a boosted board for
two years before eventually getting into
one wheeling and i could never go back
yeah but like i grew up snowboarding uh
at a certain point i started
skateboarding for a little while but
that didn't last too long and then
through college i long boarded a lot
like longboarding from where i lived to
the university campus
yeah and then electric skateboards and
then eventually one rules i've been one
wheeling for six and a half years now
but yeah it's so to answer your question
do you need balance well obviously yes
you need balance to walk
and having better balance will assist
you but you don't need to have
experience
writing this sort of thing in order to
pick it up yeah it's just a it's a time
factor you know it might just take a
little bit more time exposure this guy
freaking jake got a one wheel and two
days later was doing a curb nudge we
made a whole video about it
yes we did do you still write it jake
well it's it's under the stairs if you
behind you want to ride it oh okay
um
i leave it i leave it there just so that
way i have it if i need it when i'm
there because i don't have a car there
which is a good idea
yeah i mean you've done the steakhouse
in the one wheel before that is true
yeah i started on skateboards
and then uh
snowboarding i mean if you spend a day
or two just falling down a hill on a
snowboard and then you figure out the
snowboard
pretty much after that any board
balance based board
they all function somewhat similarly i
mean there's certain nuances to each one
in particular but
um yeah wakeboarding snowboarding
skateboarding one wheeling
uh so by the time i got the onewheel i
had
i had done most of that stuff and
um i don't know i just i had a very
athletic like
childhood i was because i had three i
had two older brothers and i was always
trying to keep up with them and and
follow them and
do the do the sports and the activities
they were doing so i had to pick things
up relatively quickly
yeah that's the the one application that
i really see it being beneficial for is
like you it's hard to find parking here
yeah and typically you have to park
really far away yeah and you guys just
zoom past me and i'm walking like a
little dork with my lunch
and you always pass me and i'm always so
jealous like morning yeah i'm at a point
now where i literally just park on
another street down the road because i
like the ride i i would prefer to have
the the confidence that there will be an
available spot and just go straight to
that and then just like one wheel a
quarter mile like it's not a big deal
yeah just pick it up put it down ride it
pick it up put it down and go to work
yeah that's the move i had a uh
interaction with a homeless guy down
this alleyway
last week that i told jake about already
but that really made me want to one
wheel because i could have just zoom
zoomed away like no problem whatsoever
but uh yeah i i was coming out from my
my car and i was i was doing the long
walk and there was a guy in a wheelchair
who was kind of like pushing himself he
had one leg she's like push himself down
the uh the alleyway and we were on a
collision course i don't know if you
know this guy maybe you've seen him
before in the alley but we were on a
collision course and i was gonna like
double back or like bide some time and
let him pass but i was like nah there's
no no real reason to do that so i had my
my phone in my one hand i was like
texting and i have my lunch and my other
one um
and
as we're getting closer to each other he
like looks over shoulder and sees me and
he goes hey hey you and i'm like oh no
dude it's like 10 in the morning not
right now and he comes he like
pulls himself with his one leg super
fast i don't know how he did i was like
like is that an e wheelchair like it was
incredible speed and he rode up to like
where he's literally touching my leg
he's so close oh and his eyes are wide
and he's just so he looks so wild i'm
just like staring him in the eyes i'm
terrified and he goes drop a lighter and
a cigarette
and i'm like no i'm sorry i don't and he
just goes
and he smacks the food out of my hand
and yeah he smacks the food and the the
carton opens and like my chicken flies
everywhere i know yeah all over the
street and i'm like whoa dude street me
whoa
relax
relax and he's like never come down here
without a lighter and a cigarette when
there's a redhead around
what and
where's the redneck what are you talking
about
please just relax so as i like make
space and then i start walking like okay
i'm gonna walk away we're all good
and i was just waiting for him to wheel
up behind me and keep it going i was
like i do not want this right now man
like anyway i made space but he was he
was cruising up and down for the rest of
the day
uh just up and down the alleyway and i
was like what alleyways is this like on
the street here sorry i say alleyway
enterprise
yeah okay yeah yeah it's kind of like an
alleyway
in a way but it was
like it was on enterprise yeah so it was
like the wildest experience i've had i
was like man that's when of one woe
would be really handy because they'd be
like hey you
[Music]
right yep oh work
pop it up go inside another real quick
though so comment again on my broken
hand here
i have specifically not made any mention
of this publicly until now
same thing with my toe so the toe when i
broke that that was because i okay that
actually was me doing some tricks on a
onewheel that wasn't me like not paying
attention uh that i i basically i was on
this ramp and i had bonked off the the
back of it and i'd landed but the the it
was a metal
lid a metal lip and the wheel it kind of
like slipped out on it so i i
stumbled off of it not a big deal except
the one wheel had gotten air and then
vertically
fell onto my foot
and it cracked my toe my big toe the
very end of it in two spots just like at
the base and then at the tip just two
little cracks
you got an x-ray yes yes and
and there's not really much you can do
with it maybe just like stay off of it
not much you can do with a broken toe
i mean like you know to fix it i guess
you can wrap it to your other tail but
like whatever um
yeah it's it's pretty much fine now i
can i can now bend it again but uh that
was like literally just imagine taking a
30 pound weight and just lifting it up
about two feet off of your foot and just
drop it nope
that was that was so nice anyway my
point is that like
i haven't talked about this stuff one
because i'm like i'm a little
embarrassed i'm like
another one
another one come on i'm becoming a
freaking caricature of myself
but the other thing is that like i
didn't want to get all the comments that
i got with the collarbone now every time
i post anything or anyone posts anything
where i'm doing something even remotely
sketchy everyone's like oh careful don't
want to lose your collarbone again
or like something like that
they'll say weird stuff like that and
it's like i see that comment all the
time now and it's like i'm very tired of
it and i'm just like i don't want to get
that with my hand is that your
kryptonite is that is that is that the
way to like make you lose your cool like
we're playing ping pong and you get in
your head
i'll be like hey ren
don't lose that collarbone and you're
like
yeah don't talk about my bones
dang it nico you just had to go and say
that now you just made this whole
problem
now people are going to specifically say
that in the comments of this video
you'll know who listens to this in the
office because next smash game somebody
will bring it up
don't lose your calling
but yeah so i'm just like i don't know
this is me trying to like can i get
through this without like talking about
it because when i broke my collarbone
last year i made a whole instagram post
i talked about it and whatnot and then
of course the shoulder surgery which was
a separate thing um and so this time
around i was just like maybe i don't
have to share this maybe this can be
just for me maybe i can just like
you know this one's for me
this one's for me
yeah and so like
i just i didn't i didn't want to make a
thing about it you know like daniel
wanted to like do the whole video
because this does impact stuff here and
there's a story to be told and i was
like i don't want to tell that story
daniel i don't really want to focus on
this i want to move on from this i'm i
don't want to break bones despite what
my experience might
show so yeah i was just
i'm like come on this
fortunately this is this hasn't been
that big of a deal it's not really
hindered my life that much i still go
one wheeling kind of intensely but it's
fine kind of intensely yeah this is ran
the 26th fastest one-wheeler on the
planet
i could i could have been faster i know
i could have been faster oh you know you
gotta try again i guess
oh man i don't know where to go with
this podcast at this point yeah you know
i saw the subreddit someone was like hey
does anyone know of any other sort of
like filmmaking podcasts i don't really
want to hear them talk about broken
bones or
their age difference and i was like this
is for that this is for that guy right
yeah yeah this is this podcast is
specifically for him
despite him
no uh so i guess we can talk about
filmmaking stuff more specifically
technology stuff no no we're on broken
bones this isn't a filmmaking frog
podcast this is this is the secret
podcast where ren reveals to the public
for the first time
his broken thumb
oh my god that's gonna be the title of
this now god dang it
like what filmmaking things can bring up
but to be honest with you this is coming
about 40 minutes into a podcast about
broken bones
it's a weird it's a weird topic barry we
should just keep this about stuff it's
not filmmaking we could keep talking
about one wheels both you and i have
been on the gt for a while yeah let's
try an impromptu gt review i mean i
suppose i have two gts now
i have one that i purchased
and one that future motion gifted to me
that
it's like
oh my god i don't know if i want to go
here
so many complex thoughts
and i don't know if this is the right
venue for it at least today
should we should we reverse out no i
mean let me put it this way
when the when the gt was announced last
october i got a text from future motion
basically saying hey don't worry we'll
get you a gt and i was like oh awesome
hell yeah this is the best ever because
i was prepared to like literally
pre-order right in the first five
minutes that i could like jan did and
and then i would have had my gt on day
one essentially and i was like very
excited for that and they're like oh
we'll get you one i was like oh even
better a free one will these things are
expensive
and then the launch of the onewheel came
and went
nothing they're like oh yeah sorry we
don't have any marketing boards to send
out right now i'm like okay
um apparently they they uh
made a i don't know what you call it
they decided to fulfill all pre-orders
before sending out boards which
is
i think a good idea
on the surface topically i think it's a
it's one of those things that looks good
on paper because they can tell their
investors that they're doing everything
that they can to like fill pre-orders
and whatnot but the problem that they
accidentally created is that they
allowed everyone who
bought their one wheels and the onewheel
community i love them there is this
there's a degree of entitlement
in the community one might say
yeah i mean you know it just comes with
the territory of a certain type of
people who who can afford a 2 000 device
and whatnot no
everyone in the community that i've ever
interacted with they've all been super
rad but nonetheless there is a degree of
entitlement and so
when the one wheel started not
meeting expectations of what like the
best possible hypothetical onewheel
could be
negative reviews started piling in like
crazy and it was a bit of a fiasco like
a legitimate fiasco on top of that there
was an actual hardware problem where the
gts were ghosting and what that means is
that the sensor that detects that you're
on it wasn't deactivating so people
would get off the one wheel but the one
wheel would think that someone's still
on it and it would just leave oh my gosh
that's like a big issue i hate to say it
it's still an issue it's still kind of
an issue i had my my brand new board
with which is supposed to not have any
problems ghost over the weekend
yeah uh unfortunately i already got it
and it didn't go anywhere and but the
wheel was spinning and so you have to
like lift the board vertically to stop
it and turning it off and back on fixed
the problem i've not had the problem
since and i've been very aware of it
but yeah so that's actually a big
problem for a company that like
existentially um and they've just been
trying to navigate all that they've
they've had a lot of
they've had a hard time this year
they've had a lot of negative feedback
but because they also fell on the wrong
side of right to repair yep well i'm i'm
confused though because did they over
promise and under deliver or was it just
people made up their own like oh it's
going to have this that and this that
because it was shrouded in a little bit
i don't they didn't really promise but
yeah a little bit of both i would say
they they what they promised they did
deliver it is a much more powerful
onewheel it goes a lot further it like
actually delivers on these things
but the complaints that were coming out
were from like very very seasoned riders
with thousands of miles under their belt
who are complaining that like the half
centimeter of extra height from the
rails being a little thicker makes it a
little bit more top-heavy and so it
doesn't handle very well the tire is
very very very hard and very rounded and
so it makes for like kind of a weird
ride and so
people are hating it to the point that
like people would get a gt and then just
like put in a closet and continue
writing their old one wheel and like
this has been going on for months and
then they eventually came out with an
update that solved most of the problems
it's still a little top-heavy the wheel
still kind of sucks but at least this
handle is better now
and yeah it was one of those that they
launched before the software was quite
ready and for software being the most
important aspect of a wheel it wasn't
quite good but they fixed it a very
clear example was when you when you went
uh when you started hitting your top
speed on the wheel the wheel tilts back
kind of makes you do a captain morgan
pose and that's to tell you like hey
you're going you're reaching the top
speed you go too much faster and the
motor won't be able to hold you up the
nose will dip
um so they had a pretty aggressive tilt
back in there the thing is when you're
going down hills you start going fast
you start hitting that point but you
have more headroom when you're going
down the hill because the motor doesn't
have to work as hard to push
so you're going down the hill you're
going down the steep hill you start to
push the top speed and slowly the bar
goes
and like slams back and even puts into
that captain morgan pose when you're
going like 20 miles an hour and that's
not that's dude it's it's so dangerous
because the moment your tail is now
scraping on the ground oh you're like
that far
down oh okay like let's just say
hypothetically if if you're tail
scraping you lose control over your
direction because it acts like a fin or
rudder i should say and you're now kind
of locked going directly straight uh
from the board's perspective but if
you're if you start losing your balance
or you're trying to go this way well
you're going one direction and your
board is going another it means you're
going to fall off yeah it's just how it
is it's happened to me many times it's
usually run it out it's not a big deal
i've run out i've had to bail off of a
board and run out
hundreds of times i'm sure uh but
imagine you're going 20 miles an hour
you're feeling fine and whatnot but
you're and you're going along the other
thing is that it would activate quickly
the pushback would happen very quickly
and it would throw you off balance and
so imagine being thrown off balance into
a situation where you're now tail
dragging at top speed geez yeah the xr
didn't do that the v1 or plus didn't do
that either and it was they fixed that
sense they fixed the since but that's
also one of those things like did you
guys have anybody that went 20 miles an
hour down a hill on this thing so i'm
convinced they didn't really do any sort
of
testing with pro writers
before the board launched
they did do a bunch of testing after the
board launch they brought in a couple of
the top writers i was talking with my
friend neil bennett who literally just
won the race that i was at last two
weeks ago he won the whole thing uh he
placed i think fifth or sixth in time
trials so he was able to get into that
top eight uh for the next day where they
actually were doing dual slalom racing
and he won anyway he he was telling me
that like
they brought him in and he spent hours
talking with the ceo and like just
describing all the things that he should
be expecting but aren't getting from the
response of the board and all this stuff
and they
and him and along with several other
writers they took their feedback and
they implemented it intelligently and
improved the board like this was the
best thing i think they've done
and it really worked but the fact that
they've always been so secretive about
everything
has been a problem you know the this is
a company where they they're inside
their they're fragmented like parts of
the company don't talk to each other you
have to have like it's almost like top
level security clearance just to go into
a certain room where they have like the
gt prototype a year ago like the
marketing team is so separated from the
rest of the company that it hurts my
soul you know these are good people i
like the guys at future motion and you
know they always mean well they're super
chill and yet they're kind of just
they've got their hands like tied behind
their backs so often which brings us
back in a full circle to what we're what
led us on this tangent here which is
they didn't send out any boards to
people yeah before they fulfilled
pre-orders
which as a marketing move goes means you
end up with everybody who's complaining
about the boards setting the
conversation yeah rather than people who
love the boards i mean i guess a lot of
people bought the boards would love the
board too but
it just becomes a negative conversation
instantly yeah and now you're fighting
that on top of everything and to be
clear there were tons of people who
loved the gt when they got them but
the people who are angry about it are
the vocal ones you know like
uh
and yeah and so this goes on for months
the the one wheel i think launched i
think in march like mid-march i think is
when jan got his he got it in the first
few days and i was like any day now i'm
gonna be sent mine and then like a month
goes by and then two months goes by and
it's like it's starting to become
evident that i'm not gonna get a one
wheeler and i got my one wheel
[Laughter]
yeah dude that was the day we shot uh
the the the challenge the
iron chef video yeah okay because you
were sitting on the couch
and you're like i did it you hit
purchase i was like
and what was crazy is that like i ended
up purchasing
mine
like three or four weeks after that
and ours arrived within the same week
yep so we were at that point where it's
like they had caught up on their
pre-orders
but even after that i didn't get much
time to gloat basically is what happened
yeah so
because here's the thing i take
onewheeling very seriously i wanted i
want to be very good at onewheeling i
want to race and i want to be
competitive i didn't get a chance last
year because i broke my collarbone a
week before the qualifying race
basically the thing i did two weeks ago
i broke my collarbone a week before that
and so i didn't even get a chance to try
and it's been driving me crazy not
knowing exactly how i stack up against
these writers because i think i'm really
good but i've not had a chance to prove
myself
and so
i know this race is coming up we're
going to have to ride gts and i'm not
getting a chance to practice
and i'm like guys i really appreciate
the thought
that you're going to give me a one wheel
but
i need a train this is and so i bought
one i just i decided to stop waiting i
decided to stop following up and so i
bought one uh that board ended up also
kind of dying the battery had this weird
issue where it was dying at 50
and so i need to send that in to get
fixed um
but i have another one wheel that i can
ride now so it's great but
they oh i only got that the new red one
wheel
a week ago the one that they sent you
yes the one that they sent me for free
very generous i appreciate it
uh
but you know it's like had they sent it
to me like right before people got their
onewheels and we had a chance to make a
video about it chances are i would have
been pretty dang positive about it i'm
positive about onewheels in general
and that could have helped shape the the
conversation in the narrative around the
new gt
but they made a decision to
fulfill all pre-orders before sending
out marketing i think they didn't want
to get the comments from investors being
like why are you sending out boards to
mr youtuber person over there when
there's still people who paid you money
who haven't received their board yet
what are you doing and it's like
arguably you sold thousands of onewheels
like if there's one person on the planet
it's like he paid for the onewheel a
hundred times over so
you know um i will like okay
they did tell me to my face at race for
the rail last year that they think i
have sold more one wheels than any
single person yeah this is coming from
the people i mean there's so many thread
on like the onewheel subreddit that said
what made you guys buy a onewheel
the vast majority of people said ren
so it's like i don't really feel bad
about getting a free onewheel they did
send me uh a pintx
uh last october and they did send me an
xr last year they have now sent me three
onewheels for free
so i have a lot of onewheels at this
point granted both my xrs are dead
the bms inside of the battery has died
and so i harvested my other bms from the
board they sent me put in that one then
that one also died because we have bms's
that are early before they paired them
to the yeah there's a whole thing and so
what i was mentioning earlier about the
right to repair the onewheel gt launched
and then it came out that if you
unplugged the battery you bricked the
board i'm getting there i'm getting
there
and
instantly huge huge
uh to stop you from repairing it
yourself yeah so basically their their
argument is that you know you should not
be repairing your board because this is
a dangerous thing
uh we don't want to have the liability
of you hurting yourself because of
something that you did
we don't want the board to die on you
when you're going 20 miles an hour and
throw you face first and and so the
whole right to repair argument is that
like really you're not going to trust us
to do something like this like a simple
little repair and
we do not have enough time to go into it
i have been paying very very careful
attention to all of this i've watched
lewis rossman's videos
i agree and disagree
two very large degrees i just yeah yeah
anyway lewis rossman is a is a youtuber
who's very into like computers and pc
builds and electronics and stuff like
that and repairing it and he's very
vocal about it and so he started going
on a huge
tirade multiple videos over the course
of a couple months again
and to a small degree there's a little
bit of shirt in front of him like yeah
get him because i have broken so many
one wheels that i've just been forced to
repair them myself but i fortunately
have the technical skill set to do that
they're not that hard to fix well
i mean to a degree you have to
well yeah i mean it's like stuff i've
opened up the xr controller module with
like the circuitry insight and i've
re-soldered components i've done that
that part's hard to fix dozens of times
now i fixed my friend's boards i fixed
my board fix my board uh your board yeah
and and it's something that the first
time i learned about it i had sent my xr
back to future motion for them to fix
but they decided that it wasn't covered
under warranty and so i had to pay 350
to fix it eventually after multiple
email exchanges i was able to get
information about what exactly was wrong
and they pointed out that the the foot
pad and the motor hall sensor they plug
into these little ports here which are
on pcbs
uh perpendicular to the actual
uh circuit board and the pins go through
that pcb and are soldered but if if you
were to pull on it too hard and then
push in on it it'll actually kind of
deep it'll it'll separate the solder and
the pin from that pcb board so it's
essentially like cutting it
the way to fix that is you just put you
just heat it back up with a little bit
of solder you reflow the solder and it
reconnects it good to go
but they didn't fix it they just
replaced it and they charged me for it
but because i was able to get
because i was able to actually get an
engineer to actually send me a photo of
the crack and point out the problem to
me i was like oh that's all i could have
done that and then i fixed i literally
turned around that evening and fixed my
v1 which had the same problem
i fixed it now i had a working one wheel
before i actually got my xr back anyway
long story short i
future motion has gone out of their way
to make it difficult to personally
repair one wheels and this has been a
problem since the beginning
but because of lewis rossman everyone
thinks this is a brand new problem
starting this year i'm like
this is like just throw it onto the list
of of the sort of anti-repair things
that they've done over the years try to
get you to stop
repairing things and so they were not a
fan of the tire replacement video that i
did four years ago at this point it was
like 2017. i was one of the first people
to ever replace a tire on a onewheel i
didn't do it a guy at a tire shop did it
but point being
um and then at some point like within
the next year
uh
i did that battery mod thing where i was
able to do it it's called charge and
ride yeah i was able to have an external
battery pack
basically go through some circuitry and
then plug into the one wheel so the
onewheel thought it was charging while i
was still writing it essentially
added another battery pack in parallel
to give you more range and i was able to
go the same distance that an xr could we
did a whole video about that on the crew
channel as well didn't like that one did
they
no and so that was the thing i got an
email from the company later that year
being like hey man
you can't be doing these uh i mean we
don't like it when you do involved mods
and make videos about them because what
you're not seeing is that behind the
scenes people
are being like oh i can do that too and
then they do it and they mess it up and
then they have to send their board in to
get repaired
and then they expect future motion to
cover it under warranty for something
they messed up which obviously they
shouldn't if if that was the case like
in future motion's credit i did kind of
like open up the case to see what the
problem was
and i put it back together and sent it
in because i didn't know what the
problem was and they're like yeah you
open up the case we we're not going to
cover that under warranty so you have to
pay 350 now
i'm okay with that because i did open it
up i'm let me phrase
i'm more okay with this i'm not okay
with just like i just opened it guys i
don't know that's they i know like
you're very
i don't know if you notice it or not but
you're very biased in their favor
because you're such a huge fan of their
product but
to to me somebody that
isn't that like i have one and i enjoy
it but
just
thinking about it
unbiasedly
they're
stodgy to a point
where it's hurting them
in terms of like what
people's perception of the product is i
think and it's i think that's pretty
clear at this point like and i think
they've realized that now yeah they they
are actually starting to improve they've
and i've talked with the guys at future
motion uh about some of their future
plans and you know like the first thing
they did is that now you can install
other people's tires on your onewheel
and
you can actually buy a spare tire and
install it yourself from future motion
this is unheard of over the last six
seven years and they're now like okay
the next problem though is that like
okay great you know what i'm totally
happy paying you to fix my battery just
swap out the component i don't care
but i live in in germany and i have to
ship my onewheel across the ocean to
freaking santa cruz to get fixed
or san jose wherever they're at if
you're gonna make it hard to repair then
give me access to places that can
replace and that's the crux of the
problem is that like okay fine
fine
i make it so that i i can't repair this
but at least make it more easy to get my
board fixed and and with only one repair
center handling all of the repairs for
the two or three hundred thousand
onewheels out there probably more at
this point that was the number i heard
like a year or two ago
um
yeah and it's short-sighted it's it's a
it's it's it's a mistake if you're a
future motion to be as stringent for not
letting people repair the boards they
try to be to not have any other avenue
for people to repair the boards is a
mistake and that's bad policy like also
there's and i think there's a whole
there's a whole avenue here in terms of
specializing and stylizing and
customizing your board to how you want
to ride it and how you want it to be
that is it's a subculture in so many
different other areas of machines or
manufactured absolutely pieces
that they're missing out on this whole
i think subculture that would really
i think foster
if if they just let it go and they let
people do cool mod videos and i get the
concern about
how you know modifying it leads them to
have a pain in the in the neck when they
have to repair something that somebody
broke but you can also fix that with
good lawyers who understand what your
manufacturing process is and who
understand what the actual internal
workings of of the company are
and you don't necessarily need to be
going oh no
so when you're denying this really
vibrant culture that could could result
from letting people do mods yeah so
something that i i think most people
fail to acknowledge and realize is
what's happening behind the scenes
future emotion is getting sued a lot
mm-hmm oh there's a lot of losses like
70 something open cases right now right
now jesus yeah and because people have
died on the one wheel people have died
falling off of it usually because they
weren't wearing a helmet and they
cracked their head open um but early on
when they i
allegedly
uh your helmets
allegedly earlier on when they first
started getting sued they settled
and oh no and so that that
put a target on their back to get sued
more again allegedly and
and and so that created the cis the
situation where now they're getting sued
all the time and that's what they
actually spend a lot of their time
dealing with is just handling all this
stuff having to go around and verifying
that
parts really haven't been tampered with
or and really were functioning correctly
but were misused all this stuff on top
of that you know it's like they have
contracts with the battery manufacturers
and suppliers uh and they have to go
through
uh pretty stringent like they should
level they should bring over well hold
on let me finish my thought like they
have to go through pretty stringent uh
ways to verify and and i'm trying to
find that right they don't want those
batteries to get out on the second-hand
market exactly and that's the battery
management captures the battery
manufacturer's saying like we'll sell
you our batteries in bulk you need to
have things in place to make sure people
can't just strip them out of the packs
and sell them again yeah and and it's
like okay that doesn't mean
that there can't be a solution here that
you know makes it so that i can unplug
my gt and it won't break itself
technically when you're raising it's
when you it's when you open the battery
compartment itself and you unplug the
bms from the battery which is a very
involved it's not just something bad
from gt it's straight up opening the
battery compartment and like messing
with the wiring in there
yeah because they basically went to an
older style
uh older method of how bms's work
whereas like when you remove the power
from the bms it wipes the flash memory
and so it essentially needs to be
reflashed in order to
work again
they phased that out of electric drills
like 15 or 20 years ago that's how they
used to do that back then
but that's like that's really really bad
and it's a dick move it is it's
absolutely but i can't i don't i'm
trying to
uh yeah amazing manufacturers saying
they have to do that yeah maybe that was
maybe they were stuck in a position
where it's like they weren't they
weren't going to be able to get their
battery unless they made an agreement
that they were gonna do this
and so now they've done that and now
everyone in the community is pissed at
them for it and it's like yeah well
they're not wrong for being pissed but
they're not fully comprehending that
maybe they they had no choice i don't
know i'm you're right i am biased i am
kind of airing on the side of defending
them when
you're definitely you definitely are and
that's fine and i get what i get while
you're saying what you're saying but
i understand it's a new technology
i understand that that results in
new
manifestations of
problems but a lot of those problems
are already have already existed in
other industries and in other products
and if
you know i
this is
you know i
if you look at this problem at a macro
level you would think
they would go and hire somebody from a
similar industry
product and compliance litigation what
have you say the auto industry or the
electric bike industry that has very
similar one-to-ones with respect to
these problems and they try to find the
best people from those industries and
bring them in and
and and because these other industries
you know you don't hear
about this as much
you know and obviously there's tons of
lawsuits in the automobile industry my
god i can't probably can't even
comprehend it
um but that also means that there's
probably some really good people that
they could find in that industry who
understand those problems pretty
intimately that they can bring on to
help solve them
yeah so that's my that's my
thought
i mean i yeah again i don't know what's
happening behind the scenes there
they're so secretive everything is all
just speculation but like
i my feeling is that they're a little
bit more strapped for cash than people
realize and that was why they had to do
the whole pre-order thing and like take
all of your money up front for the gt
even those months away from launching so
you essentially gave them an
interest-free loan
yeah which you know whatever that's fine
i i i'm not i'm not opposed to that but
classic elon musk move i mean yeah it's
like
it could definitely be that and with all
the rules and regs and costs to new
products right now with just the the
i mean there's a very clear like
overburdening of laws and regulations
when it comes to
these types of new products being
manufactured in the united states like
and
that i think that's probably a big part
of it i don't think you're wrong there
there's too much that i don't know yet
and i've been really really wanting to
like meet kyle the ceo of uh future
motion uh julian the head uh cto and
just like chat with them i wanna i
really want to understand their
perspective
right now i've been trying to understand
their perspective where i feel like most
people don't
and
and
i don't know i think that's another
thing if i was resistant to it i i would
if
again this is me just backseat driving
here but it's for the podcast let's just
go with it
yeah
if i was in their position i would say
look he wants to
he wants other people to experience the
same thing that he is experiencing with
our product that's a good thing why
don't we do that
and then allow you to speak freely once
you understand what their perspective is
so that you can at least articulate more
accurately what some of the problems are
that they're facing
that wouldn't yeah that would overall
help like people aren't stupid you know
they as long as they understand the why
to something
they can a lot of times get on board
with it
um
so i don't know that's just my take on
it
yeah jeff uh jeff mccosker from the
float life made a video kind of
uh as a proposal to the community and to
future motion being like hey here's a
middle ground that i think could work
and it was essentially just proposing
having a bunch of different service
centers across the country across the
world uh but they all have to follow
very strict guidelines like they're not
allowed to take the battery compartment
or the controller apartment apart but
they can remove the module from the one
wheel and replace it
so that's like the onewheel itself is
like legos you have like all these
different pieces they plug into each
other they have some screws and that's
pretty much it mechanically it's
incredibly simple and that's the beauty
of it once you start opening up the
controller module or the battery module
that's when things start getting a
little dicey and hairy so it's like okay
no one's allowed to do that that's fine
just replace the whole component we'll
decide whether or not it's covered under
warranty there and like you know
whatever and it's like okay and i have a
feeling future motion is going to start
going that direction but they're not
that big of a team and this is the sort
of thing that's gonna
it's gonna require a lot of uh work it's
also those things that should be in
place before the gt launched if we're
gonna talk like in a world where
everything is just done correctly like
that should have already been done i you
know yeah yeah
but they're i don't know again i don't
understand their leadership if you go on
to their glass door page you can see a
lot of like problems with communication
and secrecy and there's like everything
has to funnel through one person and
stuff like that and it's like the main
problem that i have is innovation yeah
there's the they're the only company
making a one wheel
and
they have patents preventing anyone else
from making a one wheel the euc market
the electric unicycle market there isn't
like that sort of patent for it and so
because of that there's a bunch of
companies making these ucs and because
they're competing against each other
they're trying to get better and better
and so the rate of evolution
sorry that the rate of progress on those
things has been so much faster than the
one wheel now you get these euc's that
go 50 miles an hour 400 miles and they
got full suspension yeah it's like
insane on one wheel i would not get off
there's one sitting in the other room
mark yeah
that
it was pretty gnarly no wonder
that one will go like 40 i think
so 40 miles an hour is my stupid that's
death speed if you fall off and you're
not at least i need at least two wheels
to go over 50.
yeah
i guess what i'm saying is like that's a
frustration of mine is that you know it
was four years between the xr and the gt
and yes they doubled the range yes they
made it more powerful
technically the the magnets in the new
uh
rotor
are a little bit more powerful than the
xr motor
magnets so it's not exactly the same
motor
but it's essentially the same motor
and it's like
i don't know after four years
of innovation is a little disappointing
i wanted a little bit more too the low
end torque is like maybe five percent
better than the xr it feels like you
know it's like it doesn't get over bumps
and like steep hills from a stop any
better than the xr really does once
you're moving you had a higher speed
it's got more punch for sure like it is
definitely a more powerful wheel than
the actual especially at speed if you're
going 20 miles an hour
i know well i can't i can hit 20 miles
an hour easily on the gt and i'm
comfortable i can't do that in the xr
like that's my lifetop speed on the xr
it's like 20 miles an hour and the gt i
hit 20 miles an hour on my first night
writing it
my top speed on the gt is 25.9 how do
you know this does it say it it says on
the app oh cool yeah
yeah and so yeah and so
yeah so no one can
it's the only option
and i've fallen in love with the
platform of the onewheel i'm i'm certain
i'm convinced that the fundamental
basics of what a one wheel is is never
going to go away yeah there was a couple
years there i was a little worried
because they were the only person now
but now there's a whole diy movement in
fact let's let's let's have this be our
nice like resolution to this whole story
here as we wrap up this podcast the hope
maybe not hope on the horizon but the
interesting light rising up on the
horizon
should we should we reveal what we're
doing
yes oh let's come clean
yes we've been ready i've been talking
about if we should talk about this
publicly because like we don't want to
like you know like you're saying is
there's very much so a senpai uh
situation here you know like future
motion and senpai and i'm like notice me
they're like yeah you sold more one
wheels than anyone else i'm like yeah
you noticed me
but
nico and i are going to build our own
diy one wheel
you using an open source platform called
vesc
we've already bought the components for
it
in fact i think the controller module
literally just arrived today oh awesome
was supposed to arrive yesterday it
didn't we actually have
some we have like not just bought some
modules we have some models being given
to us by people that are
also helping to i mean not given we
bought them but
oh wait you're right we did buy them no
didn't the batteries okay yes okay
battery systems high battery systems
super big shout out uh they did gift us
the most
uh most expensive component which was
this 84 volt 20 cell battery pack
much higher voltage than even the gt the
gt is an 18 cell battery pack the xr was
a 15 cell battery pack the higher that
the cell count the higher voltage the
more power you can get without having to
pump as many amps and so
oh my god i can't wait uh yeah so
theoretically like
the more voltage you have it it lends
the wheel more more power more more
torque no amperage average would be
torque wouldn't it voltage would be top
speed i don't know it's a mix
yeah it's going to have more power
and so it can climb steeper hills
not interested in a higher top speed but
that being said we also have
a new motor on order it's not out yet
but we're on the first batch of
pre-orders it's a 2 000 watt hub motor
compared to the 750 watts oh my gosh of
the of the gt
and so
that'll just that just means it'll have
more higher
uh ability to put out the power it won't
over my biggest problem with the gt is
that it overheats every ride i've gone
on it's overheated on almost every
single ride because i'm pushing it
so it's like it's a bit of a you know
it's a bit of a vibe killer when you're
going along and and like the motor
literally overheats and it's like hey
you have to kind of give it a break and
it's like
okay just sit here and wait this is like
when we
uh did all that work to get uh origin
pcs
remember way back in the day yeah
there's nothing really wrong with origin
pcs but they kind of were half-assed
about it and and we didn't have any
options at the time and so we did what
we had to do and we got some good
origins for the time but
then puget came along
oh my gosh
it was the clouds part of the angels
showed up yeah exactly
and and they go wait what have you guys
been dealing with oh oh yeah you you
need what oh oh yeah oh yeah and
and you know and then they tell us now
they go hey guys you know the the fact
that you guys
love them and use them and promote them
just by using them
has done more to sell
pugets than
we we could have thought and you know i
think i think they're missing a little
bit of that here i think i think one
wheel's missing a little bit
yeah this is where it gets hard because
it's like i very much so want to be part
of their team excuse me
like not officially but like i want to
help like i want future motion to
succeed i want more onewheels out there
i want to so much so that i think i have
good ideas and i want to like help them
and i'm met with the wall
and it's been that way the entire time
of our relationship again this isn't
like a personality guys who are part of
future motion that i interact with
personally are great but again their
hands are tied
yeah it might be time to build boys
that's awesome
it is we literally already have so i've
got the batteries at home thankfully the
open source movement
has basically put all the pieces
together necessary to build a one wheel
and when it's open source you can get
around the patent issues
and uh just can't sell it all as one
package right yes
but these things come with you know
people need to do testing people need to
figure out the software people need to
figure out the settings like how much
response time do you need on your you
know when you put push down on the front
pad like is the ipd values like so
there's all this kind of stuff that
people have had to work out and like
there's surf dotto there's like you know
there's the mad max guys putting a lot
of awareness there's all these people uh
there's the best man best man
uh what are something like the shops
like there's uh
fun
the engineers engineers yeah that's who
we got the motor from makers pev yeah
try battery systems like so all these
people are coming together i mean of
course float life with their rails and
all the pieces they're doing too like
all these people are coming together and
putting the pieces together and it's
been rough until about a few months ago
i think the gt stuff really put people
over the edge being like you know what
this isn't what i wanted
i guess i'm gonna have to make it myself
and
like it's it's inevitable soon it's
gonna be at the point where it's like
okay there's tutorials there's pieces
you can go out and build your own at
least that'll be an option if for some
reason
stuff gets too bad at future motion and
the thing employ and that company
implodes at least there'll be this
avenue for us think about it yeah think
about blender showing up on this yeah
and then 3ds max like yeah you know what
i mean blender started rough man yeah
you should be great like blender blender
came up out of nowhere and was really
rough at the start and now it's like you
could do everything in there because
that was the thing is that like the
hardware has been around to do these
self-balancing boards for a long time
but the firmware hasn't been there the
software actually like it's more than
just like get underneath the person when
when it detects an orientation changes
it's so much more complicated than that
did you know that the wheel actually
accelerates even more when you turn
it's like there's an actual acceleration
that happens when you turn and that's
just like one of one of like a million
different like subtle things and so
it's only really been the last like six
months or so that the firmware is
finally starting to get to a point where
it's starting to kind of feel like a
normal one wheel and wow and two future
motions credit they cracked that code
you know yeah five six years ago and
that's why and it's still not there it's
still not actually there the desk like
it's it's getting close but it's not
yeah uh christian's telling us to wrap
up
last question real quick how fast can
you go on these on like a vest it's it's
i mean
can you hit 50 no
okay
[Laughter]
but now we're at a point where all of
the different components
exists as third-party components the
only things that are still like
like the boards we're about to make we
have our own third-party rails motor
tire uh bumpers foot pads the only and
controller they actually don't have
third-party foot pads but there are
there is a third-party foot pad we could
use if we want but future motion makes
the best one and we already have them so
we might as well use it that's kind of
where we're at same thing with the
battery
box we have our own battery but it sits
inside of a box that we're harvesting
from an old xr
and listen
the gt is an incredible device it is an
incredible one wheel it's like if you
get a one wheel gt it will blow your
mind it will be incredible but we are
like in the top point zero one percent
of writers pushing it beyond those
we want more things like we've been
doing this for so many years now that
like you know what i want to have
another one that i do have control over
the options one where i can see the
battery voltage of all the individual
cells see that's the problem my one
wheel that i bought
is broken it doesn't work it dies at 50
percent and i am unable to diagnose
what's wrong with it
because they removed the freaking
battery voltage for each cell so that
you couldn't diagnose it and the battery
voltage in general oh that too like i
literally like on the x sorry this is
where we're gonna just fade out just
keep going
it's stupid and it's really frustrating
because it's like i would i would like
to diagnose what's wrong but i literally
can't i have to
physically mail the board back to them
just to find out what's wrong
anyway
the onewheel is awesome but you know
what we're also going to build around
yep we'll do maybe a dedicated podcast
about that or something maybe a video
who knows maybe a video we'll see yeah
first we got to make them yeah yeah jake
sing about battery voltage
all right
84 volts is the pretty late
63 is the current lady i got
and it went all right
i had a battery volt
and it revolted before my eyes oh look
at that word play what am i gonna do
i don't know dude this totally did i got
a battery
[Music]
glad you could be with us jordan thanks
for watching everybody i hope you
learned something christian i could see
him and his eyes starting to glaze over
i could see jake's eyes gloss over i
could see your eyes gloss over this is
nico and i here we're the only two
people in this podcast see you next week